foreign
let's go now to the City of Angels Los
Angeles California Jody is there Jody
how can we help
hi there I'm so glad I got you guys
today thanks for taking my call oh well
thank you
um so we're the reason we decided to
call in my husband and I um is we're a
big fan of the Ramsey method uh three
years ago he paid off over 230 000 of
student loan debt wow over about
the worst three years of Our Lives
they were worth it so you know um we
know that that you guys know what we
should do uh we're caught up we're both
Freelancers we're both in the film and
television industry we're not writers
but we're very much caught up in the
writer's strike oh no
we're not we're not able to find
anything that's kind of relevant and
even you know the few things that we do
find everybody else is looking for work
in the same things everybody else is
scratching around and so we're having a
hard time where this is what I wanted to
get your advice about is you know when
we're applying for jobs uh just to you
know keep moving forward and not have to
you know to protect our emergency fund
like you guys were just talking about
um we're finding that people don't want
to hire us knowing that we're going to
leave in a couple of months um anything
that seems like it would utilize our
skill set or or you know just our
education are just like well you guys
are going to go back to your real life
in a couple of months or you know five
months or six months however long it
lasts and you know clearly we're not
afraid of hard work
um and you know I've been thinking a
cleaning job you know for the past
couple of weeks just to you know have
something to to do during the day that
feels like it's bringing money in but it
really brings in so little money and you
know it just feels like it's it's
something that you do and there's not
anything else you can do what do you
guys guys need to make
I mean we have four months emergency
fund ready for this we kind of knew that
this was coming so nothing is dire
um but you know our operational budget
really is it about if we don't save
towards our house we're renting right
now if we don't do anything we want to
talk about Bare Bones this just gets you
yeah Bare Bones four thousand seven
hundred dollars we just had a budget
meeting okay great I love that you've
got a bare bones and uh so what do you
guys do what is what is what do you do
what are your husband what does he do
we're both film and TV um editors so uh
it feels like you know we have like one
of the most popular skills in the world
for this current world but we just
somehow still are having a hard time
finding some net utilizers yeah and
forgive me for the silly question does
that mean that you guys are actually
editing footage
yes yes so what we do is we've been on
some shows uh actually that your
producer is like oh do you want to sell
me some of your credits someone tell me
and I was like uh Maybe not maybe my
friends might get worried about me if
they're listening so gotcha yeah yeah we
don't have to do that but we've worked
for HBO we've worked for AMC we've
worked on some on some shows that you
would definitely okay so the first thing
that comes to mind is is less LA and
more freelance
um we we I have a good friend who
um is is is a pretty he's a pretty
substantive producer works out of his
house in my neighborhood in Franklin
Tennessee
and uh freelance work outside of the
movie and television industry is where I
would be looking and what I mean by that
is you've got you've got people doing
videos all the time social media you've
got companies that need I would be
looking I'd be scouring online for some
freelance video editing because you guys
bring to the table all the skills
necessary to actually just do the video
and this is not stuff that's in La so
you're not scrambling and fighting for
it uh it's remote I'd be looking there
gig work like that where you're doing
any kind of video editing I'd be looking
for that uh remote that's where I would
start
um as it relates to the issue of well
people don't want to hire us I think
you're going to have to do some of that
like you know work I was talking about
like I'm not saying your husband's got
to go do construction but you're looking
for a type of manual labor that pays
really well proud if he's working in a
warehouse and he's making 18 to 20 bucks
an hour slopping boxes again this is not
a step backwards this is just
this is good old-fashioned character we
don't want to touch our emergency fund
and and I'd be looking for Gig work like
that where they don't care you know what
I mean
um
they were kind of asking like what can
you commit for a year you know and we
were like no we can't you know even for
dog walking stuff like they just don't
want to do they want to eat your
commitment
they wanted we've had two different jobs
that we've applied for that wanted a
one-year commitment for taking people's
Bichon freezes outside the P I mean I
don't understand it's crazy you know so
maybe that's our Market in particular
because we do have a lot of people who I
mean even in the best of times are
actors and people who want to have side
hustles maybe they're they're all burnt
out
um but I really do like the idea of just
trying to find something that is purely
remote purely online I know that people
in town aren't could you get connected
with like a wedding videographer and
then they could offload the editing to
you
I mean of what
that's right um but you know there could
be someone who's doing gangbusters but
you know that that that takes some
hunting for sure I mean I mean that's my
best idea I again I I don't think that
every warehouse job I don't think that
every I don't think every job needs a
one-year commitment you know and and
here's the reality if if it gets to that
point
work is work and if they're ready to
hire me and they're going can you commit
for a year you go I don't know I don't
know I'm in between things right now I
don't know if I can come in or not but
I'm ready to work right now and if that
doesn't work fine but what we've got to
do is we've got to get to the point
where that doesn't matter they're
looking for somebody and we're gonna pay
you x amount an hour if you're gonna
stock grocery shelves whatever you got
to do what we're trying to do is is one
way or another for the next two three
four months I don't think the strike is
going to stretch six months I don't I
don't think that do you
I
I I'm hoping so that's what I think I
think you guys got to figure out 30 days
that's what I think and so I would I
would just be doing whatever and I love
the online model you can't believe
somebody y'all's background you could be
maybe teaching some classes online and
you guys are out that you're not out
there schlapping you know you're you're
in your home you're doing stuff that
you're really good at how do you
transfer the skill and experience you
have to some online jobs out there where
people need talent and it's just plug
and play that's where I would be
starting and again I would be looking
for anything manual labor that they know
it's transient they just need somebody
to come in that's where I would be
looking yeah I do love Ken's idea of
social media that's such a huge one is
these businesses or entrepreneurs or
creators they're not great at editing
and you guys are experts at that if I
could hire someone like you are you
kidding me at a fraction of your actual
rate I'd be chomping at the bit and so I
would be contacting creators out there
on Instagram and videos you see that you
say hey here's where we're at we're in
the writer strike we're looking for work
right now we're willing to cut you a
really good deal to cut you some really
great social media work that can help
you increase your impact what do you
think and I think just getting real
creative and persistent you guys will
get some amazing gigs and that word of
mouth will spread and hopefully you'll
be back to work in no time and one other
idea Jody this is at least worth kicking
around but you know I'm thinking you
think about the East Coast if there's
some production companies in Nashville
Charlotte North Carolina I'm just
picking cities and they're looking for
some part-time editing I would be
jumping on that they'd hire you in a
second do you know what I'm saying
right right now we definitely have the
credits you have the resume I mean it
feels crazy sending an editing resume
with you know movies and TV to a
waitressing job they just look at you
and go what is this so they've got to
understand they know how strikes work I
don't think anyone looks down at that
and goes what are you guys doing here
they go wow I really respect that you're
looking to make ends meet and do
whatever it takes I'd be shocked Jody if
there aren't several freelance editing
video editing jobs that are posted from
all across the country that would be a
good short-term fix for you guys that's
what I think
so that's really good that's a very a
good place to start I really appreciate
it I hope there's something there I just
gotta believe there are because they
don't want full-time they can't but they
need somebody on a short term level and
you guys could come in and make quick
work of that and as good as you guys are
you might be able to pick up three four
five six jobs over a 30 45 day period
and it's just gravy and it gets you
through that's what that's what I would
try so thanks for trusting us and Carl
I'm sorry you're dealing with this
um here's what I know Jody I just think
it's going to get done a lot sooner than
you think because the industry was
already hurting coming out of covid it
started warming back up and now this
nonsense so I think they're gonna fix it
pretty quick it just can't keep going
our hearts go out to all of you
effectively Rider strikes so many people
not just the writers it's so everyone
involved in in making great film and TV
here's a great example as to why the
emergency fund why getting out of debt
matters it allows you to weather storms
like this beautiful work